I would imagine this comes up a lot I'm
wondering if I write Halle Schwartz a
letter and I tell them you know listen I
would love it if you could waive the fee
and I will do this this and this to
reciprocate for that money are you able
to then take my film and waive that fee
well my answer to that would be no yes I
we weren't we're not a UH
we're not a fan of the fee waiver
request many festivals maybe probably
agree with me some festivals maybe don't
really offer a lot of waivers now there
are some small instances of things like
okay if I say I do there really is only
instance if I go to a festival and I see
your film and I'm like I got to have it
I'm telling you I want like I'm
essentially at your door begging you for
your film then obviously in fairness I'm
telling you to submit it you know I
should either worst case offer your
discount at war
you know maybe away the fee but they
don't do that ever I don't ask for films
anymore we don't ask for films really at
all so it's really about to me it's not
just about the financial aspect it's
about the actual fairness of the process
if you feel your film is worthy you're
good enough for that
well many others are so why are we
waving just one feed just cuz you asked
for it and everyone else is paying full
price and what's the difference
why should I offer you this this this
this nice gift like for what like what
just to ask for it is not a good enough
reason and even if there are sending
standard situations or you know your we
hear all types of stuff whether it's the
financial stuff I know obviously
especially for student filmmakers
obviously a lot of times money is tight
you're a student you're in college I
understand that for that part of it that
I get that but then you have to hand
pick what festival you trying to submit
to and and all this stuff and you got to
make a plan you know and as you gotta
just make something happen you can't
just say hey I want a favor because I'm
having some struggles right and we all
have struggles in life we all have
things I was in college and broke you
had to pay for certain things I wanted
it to pay for make it happen you don't
just ask for that because you feel you
deserve it and so maybe there's a
certain element of offense it's
offensive in some ways to me I just
don't personally don't like it I'll try
to answer as many as I can't answer
people to just assault handli we do not
take waivers and that's it
at times if if there are some
circumstances where we like the email
feel like someone's really making a good
effort there's real reason behind
something or
or whatever I don't know or you know we
can always say look there are certain
situations where we have discounts with
promo partners and things and look them
up and if you see their formal thing and
they send the code outter you know you
have a disc an out there you get a
discount but that's all we can do
yourself to pay because it's just the
principle of it
everyone's submitting and paying so in
the canoe get accepted you don't pay and
then they pay their good money and then
get in or they got in you know why are
you getting the same equal benefit for a
submission for you know so again not
that it's any every dollar counts but
we're not our fees aren't like you know
like your you know something $5 to
submit to a festival no it adds up for a
lot of festivals I get that but our fee
is what our fee is I don't care whether
festival's charged or how many Fester's
you're submitting to for us we're
looking at it as you should submit to
ours we feel it's in that caliber and
and it's in the range of 35 to 70 or so
dollars range of early to leave you
submitted last day it's obviously higher
if it's meant that right now early bird
it's anywhere from 35 to 40 bucks it's
not something need to take donate blood
for I mean it's a cure it's not you know
it's just and then again I don't want to
come across as too flippant or anything
I just it's it's just to me it is
something that it takes the time from my
day or any of our day or hour in terms
of assistance or anyone to answer these
emails to even at all which some of them
suppose we can't even catch up on or
sometimes we want most wondering why
even bother answering like something
like do I have to answer you I don't
have to I mean you know but we are at
least trying to be kind enough to at
least get back to people so that we you
don't offer waivers it's just it's just
something that isn't even a time thing
like oh it's early in later or depending
on what's the fee it's just it's not
something I feel the principle always
has been whyever is everyone else paying
and what makes you different than you
feel your's more special than you don't
have to pay just based on you know
either not just struggle but hey I my
films that good and I just think it
shouldn't and that's also touch on that
that bugs me even more I'm people like
the filmmakers should never reference
hey I played this festival that
festivals so that means obviously I'm at
a certain place I got in some festivals
but now here way my fee for this one
okay let me ask you this did you submit
those festivals in Bay Yeah right yes
you did
I'm assuming yes okay so now you're
telling me my festival is not worthy of
submitting the fee and paying you gotta
do those festivals but then you didn't
like the hypocrisy of that that bugs me
to no end I go okay you're telling me
you
fess already so obviously we assume you
paid the submission for yeah I highly
doubt they gave your waivers and at
times I used to get mad I would actually
say it to people like also did you pay
this via and no answer like it you paid
their fee so you're telling me now
you're not gonna pay our submission fee
at a moderate rate just because you just
played there already and now you just
don't want to pay our fee then that
obviously you do not inherently notice
how offensive that can be festival to
say you're telling me we played them
first we play with that you know hey
it's gonna be personal you're telling me
you played there and paid there and you
don't want to pay for us so you're
saying what you ran out of money now you
don't want to pay or you just don't want
to pay period and just you're gonna ask
for something because you now feel you
have a sort of more special thing going
because you've been accepted so it's
great awesome that the films come to us
and we know hey they made these
festivals is great all good but again
everyone else is paying so I just don't
I just you know now I know there are
circumstances of of you know other
countries like Iran comes up a lot they
cannot pay fees or there's sanctions for
credit cards and things that we hear
about I don't know the political
situation quite frankly of how much that
is fully accurate and I believe it is to
be we still get submissions from Iran at
times and they pay I don't know how they
do it I don't know what but they come in
and they do and then those that don't
then we get emails from we get emails
from there every day probably five
emails a day maybe ten absent free
waivers and I just I can't open the
floodgates there if I say yes you no one
pays you guys don't pay and then so now
all these films get to not pay but
everyone else is paying I've even asked
people like looking someone else pay for
you I mean there's other countries other
people if someone you know and states or
in LA or whatever you know offer
discount something but you got it just
it just has to be the principle of you
just offering all these waivers of
people now we have to spend our time and
resources for staff to watch these films
this doesn't work for us I just I don't
I don't see it as being something that's
equitable or fair I know it's tough with
those kind of countries sanctions I
think that that's a tough situation but
for us we haven't really figured way to
solve that you know this time quite
frankly and being honest I just you know
I know some other festivals do just
completely waive fees for for Iran and
things like that like feeling like okay
they can't pay and that kind of stuff I
just it's something we feel like we can
do with our resources on our team size
and things I just it's just not
something I just yeah so we don't just
poner that and many times the emails if
it's not with any good effort or any
good reason it's just it is kind of it's
yeah I look I
people always say right like get me ask
for you got to ask right hey you don't
ask you know receive like at least ass
throw it out there why not but if you do
submit then finally if you don't have
submitting so you're asking for a waiver
I'm gonna say no and then you don't
submit and I your phone never plays
never gets in and what was the point of
all that I think if you put that time in
it out those emails like you can put
your time at something else so that's
you know yeah well I mean I don't go
into you know I'm not gonna go into the
local coffee shop and say hey could you
just give me this one yeah exactly
latte for free this time is that you
know it to me it's there's nothing
different I don't even see how there is
someone how they can look at it it's
anything different I don't and it's yeah
that's exactly a good point it's good
analogy it's like they're not gonna walk
into some store and say hey give it to
me free just be just because all right
whether we have struggling now everyone
has some struggle I mean I we again it
was in a position of real struggle on
college and it was you found things away
I did you know you do what you got to do
to survive and get baiance them you
don't just like ask for things just
because you feel you're in a different
place or especially what else are you
you don't have to pay just because you
don't want to all right so those kind of
you know like I just don't understand
like you're just basically telling me
you just don't feel like paying so
you're gonna ask it's it's really odd to
me if you think about any other business
I get people just all with the Starbucks
and they had ten people a day coming in
asking for free cup of coffee it's not
happening and imagine if it was like
you're like no and you know I just yeah
it's really a bizarre thing I guess it's
just something that is as part of this
business and it's a it's it's an
inherent with it but it's definitely
different and unique to this because
again like you said you're not Starbucks
is getting bombarded with free offers
every day for you know customers just
saying hey look I want this one free
this time you know look it's just it's
just I don't know it's it's a yeah but
it definitely is a definitely peppy for
many programmers and festivals I would
imagine them speaking for others maybe
some don't care as much or like it or I
don't know but obviously most most don't
like it and are not appreciative of that
email all the time spends on that so
definitely yeah
yeah it's they just don't
[Laughter]
you